[Musique]
exploitant céréalier depuis 98 1998 et
on a pris un petit tournant dans notre
activité professionnelle en en 2009 2009
stéphane un jour s'est levé en décidant
ont fait de la pomme de terre
ok on fait de la pomme de terre départ
un hectare surface 1 ha 25 en 2009 et
aujourd'hui
pratiquement 10 hectares 9 hectares on
se concentre sur ça parce que toute
l'année il ya du travail
donc on achète on achète deux plans
voilà donc et en big bag dans notre en
contenant donc on prépare le terrain à
l'avant son labo on affine maximum voilà
nous dans notre façon de procéder ont
pris but d'abord avant de planter on
plante dans la butte et en rebute
derrière pour affiner encore un maximum
pour l'arrachage quoi on est qu'il y ait
moins de monde possible à l'arrachage 65
tonnes ça dépend de 30 et 50 tonnes ha
de récolter quoi la demande qu'on a à
faire on fait de pas mal de polyvalente
qui puisse faire la cuisson enchère
ferme enfin chair ferme et aussi pures
et frites on adapte aussi les variétés
part pour maladie donc on est toujours
on en change de variétés suivant les
années
et ça risque de changer encore par
rapport à des nouvelles variétés qui
vont être plus résistante au mildiou des
maladies de tubercules pour pour limiter
les traitements tout ça à la mi-avril
oui jamais avril seront plantés en buts
définitivement ensuite il ya
d'irrigation après l'été et puis après
l'arrachage alami la mi août et après la
récolte pour la conservation pour
l'hiver c'est de du 20 août au 20
septembre
ce son stock après qu'on a encore un
arrache donc on met ça en stockant palox
en ranch à un chambre froide
donc mon anti germain c'est fini donc on
n'en parle plus depuis pas nous on ne
fait plus depuis longtemps un mais on
garde ça
à 4 4 et 5 degrés ça nous permet d'avoir
des pommes de terre pendant 12 mois puis
la partie carottes
depuis deux ans la troisième marche
là aussi on augmente toujours on double
pratiquement tous les deux ans tous les
ans on avait commencé à éplucher en 2016
les petites des petites quantités avec
les restaurateurs les associations avec
pour des fruits de l'été tout ça mais du
coup il ya eu le développement d'agri
locale en janvier 2017
on a joué le jeu au départ et puis
finalement ça ça finit par porter ses
fruits bout de plusieurs mois 60 à 80%
c'est une nouvelle c'est une nouvelle
façon de travailler pour les chefs aussi
qu'ils doivent s'adapter aux produits
locaux avec l'idée de ces courtes et des
produits frais ici la pomme de terre
avec te ment dans l'assiette donc si ça
va pas on le sait tout de suite
et là faut réagir très vite et si ça va
on sait tous et ce qui est super c'est
quelqu'un que ça va bien comme çà doit
on est on le sait aussi français aussi
c'est le bon côté du les producteurs en
direct
[Musique]